vous allez voir une scène dans laquelle
vous allez voir deux individus et
spontanément je vais vous demander de
juger le niveau de dominance de la
personne de droite de 1 à 5 d'accord la
personne de droite ok bah là je vois une
femme qui est pas contente parce que son
mari ou son mec boit un verre je vais
dire
ok donc
là maintenant vous voyez cette scène là
jugez le niveau de dominance de la
personne de droite là je vois un type
qui va mettre une taloche à sa femme ou
à sa copine donc ouais donc je dirais
quatre cinq
donc on imagine qu'en fait on a fait ça
pour plein d'images avec plein de
participants en fait ce qui semble
apparaître mais qui reste encore à
confirmer c'est que les individus qui
paraissent les plus dominants qui sont
jugés les plus dominants sont les hommes
et surtout quand ils le sont vis-à-vis
d'une femme en fait et mais c'est la
même photo dans les deux cas c'est la
même photo
mon enquête commence mal
gré ma vigilance je tombe dans le
premier piège des tests de perception
sur les femmes et le pouvoir
pourtant depuis mon enfance je suis sûre
de jouer dans la même cour que les
garçons
avec les mêmes atouts et les mêmes
règles du jeu
à 8 ans je découvre une première
ministre anglaise qui mate tous les
chefs d'État son terrain de jeu l'Europe
lui semble à sa mesure
vous avez moins de 40 ans vous êtes né à
Strasbourg vous êtes de quelques années
plus tard ma ville natale Strasbourg et
la première métropole à élire à sa tête
une femme sans que personne ne s'en
office pas même celui qu'elle a sorti de
la mairie et qu'on ne taxe pas encore à
cette époque de mal blanc de plus de 50
ans
nous on est très étonné par une image
est-ce que le réalisateur peut vous
montrer aux côtés de Monsieur Rudloff
vous semblez tous les deux oh j'ai pas
l'impression que vous soyez vraiment des
ennemis vous avez l'air de vous faire
des sourires vous avez l'air de ça a
l'air de bien se passer entre vous
c'est vrai
bien écoutez je n'ai jamais de mes prix
ni de superbes à des gardes mes
adversaires je me bats pour mes idées et
ce sont mes idées qui en portent et mes
amis avec moi je n'ai pas l'égoïsme de
prétendre que cette victoire est la
mienne Sun ces images ont plus de 30 ans
allez voir on dirait que notre histoire
piétine surtout quand on découvre que la
promotion des femmes ou haute fonction
de pouvoir reste encore un sujet je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour la première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions et dites cresson alors
pourquoi les femmes ont-elles encore
tant de mal à incarner le pouvoir
l'exerce-t-elle autrement et cela
augure-t-il d'un avenir différent
pour comprendre ce qui se joue quand on
accole ces termes pouvoir et féminin
nous avons soigneusement sélectionné
deux femmes tombées dans l'éprouvette du
pouvoir il y a peu
Léonore me conduit mère de Poitiers
écologiste élue au lendemain de ses 30
ans la jeune mère de Poitiers incarne le
renouvellement des pratiques et des
styles d'une nouvelle génération
[Musique]
à première vue tout l'oppose à notre
deuxième cobaye myder a rose Tigui venu
de la droite classique et élu en même
temps à l'été 2020 dans la chic et
impériale cité de Biarritz
je n'ai pas la droite honteuse je suis
une femme de droite mais j'ai une liste
qui est un rassemblement d'hommes et de
femmes qui ne sont pas forcément de
droite et c'est ça justement l'ADN de
notre mais les deux nous révèle détenant
point commun quand on observe de plus
près leur pratique du pouvoir
une pratique que nous ferons raisonner
avec les toutes dernières recherches en
neurosciences ou primatologie
des travaux qui permettent de mieux
comprendre pourquoi l'attelage femme et
pouvoir des chaînes depuis toujours
aussi bien les passions que les
stéréotypes
et nous avons voulu savoir à cette
occasion s'il y avait une manière
féminine de gouverner ne frottaient pas
mieux de s'occuper de leur mari ou de
leurs enfants leur place est-elle au
Parlement et les dérapages ne date pas
d'hier par exemple une femme ministre
qui répond à une question et j'entends
dans les travées à poil
non pas du tout en quoi on doit renoncer
à ce que vous appelez la féminité
j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs qu'on dit ce
que c'est que la féminité je sais ça ça
éclairerait les gens
que ce soit l'image idéal de la féminité
[Musique]
je sais pas si le pouvoir a un sexe en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
a une histoire et que et que depuis des
siècles voire des millénaires il se
décline au masculin
[Musique]
la France se caractérise ce singularise
en tout cas dans le concert des nations
et notamment des nations européennes par
une
par une propension particulière à
exclure les femmes du pouvoir et à faire
en sorte d'identifier le pouvoir au
masculin
on se rappelle notamment sous la
monarchie de la fameuse loi dite salique
qui a consisté à exclure les femmes du
trône et le résultat c'est que la France
a été le seul pays en Europe où le mot
renne n'a plus désigné que l'épouse du
roi
[Musique]
on a eu des reines de transition pendant
la minorité des rois etc mais on a pas
eu des reines de plein exercice et le
pouvoir se caractérise donc sans doute
plus que dans d'autres démocraties par
des signes du masculin
un point de détail les hommes politiques
ont un costume pour faire de la
politique les femmes n'en ont pas
la question du vêtement qui pourrait
apparaître comme complètement secondaire
se pose systématiquement quand une femme
s'engage en politique
[Musique]
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est que
s'engager dans la vie politique et bien
c'est avoir le sens de la compétition
beaucoup plus que de la coopération du
travail collectif on l'a vu récemment
avec l'épisode de Valérie Pécresse lors
de la présidentielle de 2022 là encore
c'est code oratoires ont été forgés au
masculin
avec cette force je veux rallumer avec
vous les espoirs d'une nation unique et
universelle une nation bâtie par des
femmes et des hommes qui par leur
travail leur bravoure leur génie
artistique et scientifique ont réussi à
hisser la France au premier rang
Valérie Pécresse par ailleurs à la fois
bon oratrice et extrêmement consciente
des enjeux liés à la prise de parole et
me semble-t-il tomber dans le piège lors
de son premier grand meeting du Zénith
puisqu'elle a essayé de singer des
façons de faire qui était
identifiée finalement un art oratoire au
masculin pour un ordre juste contre tous
les désordres injustes qui frappe les
plus faibles pour des énergies positives
qui se rassemblent et des libertés
nouvelle à inventer bon Ségolène Royal
première femme candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui est arrivée jusqu'au
jusqu'au 2e tour à jouer de tous les
codes du féminin c'est-à-dire qu'elle a
à la fois me semble-t-il jouer sur les
codes de la séduction
puisqu'on se rappelle
les modifications qui ont été apportées
sur le plan physique avant la campagne
électorale elle a retravaillé un petit
peu son visage
retravailler sa coiffure adopter des
codes vestimentaire éminemment féminin
toujours en robe etc et sur le plan du
discours elle a elle a mis en avant son
statut demeure ce qui lui a valu
d'ailleurs à la fois d'être vilipendée
par les féministes parce que mettant en
avant son statut demeure et par d'autres
parce que mettant en avant une forme de
séduction déclinée au féminin mais
est-ce que c'est pas un problème de code
en fait finalement on est dans un monde
où les codes du pouvoir sont très
masculins et donc comment inventer des
codes de féminin elles n'ont pas su
inventer un code du pouvoir qui qui leur
corresponde alors un code du pouvoir ça
s'invente pas seul les codes ça doit
être le fruit d'une évolution d'une
collectivité d'un consensus je veux
la France souveraine qui le soit soumise
à faire et voilà comment nous qui
regardons ces images nous nous
retrouvons d'emblée parties prenant de
l'enquête et du jeu de pouvoir nous avec
nos croyances nos convictions mais aussi
nos réflexes et nos a priori parfois
très archaïques comme le montre les
travaux de Jean-Baptiste van danermst
alors là de quoi il s'agissait ce matin
c'était quel type d'expérience à la tête
d'une équipe de recherche il a piloté
toute une série d'expériences
confrontant des enfants à la notion de
pouvoir dans celle-ci très troublante
[Musique]
donc sur l'image il y a deux enfants
et il y en a un qui dit à l'autre
tu vas faire tout ce que je veux
et l'autre il dit d'accord je vais faire
tout ce que tu veux à votre avis c'est
lequel qui dit tu vas faire tout ce que
je veux c'est lequel celui-là
à celui qui fait comme ça d'accord et
qui va et qui dit d'accord je vais faire
tout ce que tu veux
OK et maintenant si on dit qu'il y a un
garçon et une fille à ton avis c'est qui
le garçon c'est qu'il a fille
c'est le garçon c'est celui qui pointe
le doigt d'accord ces expériences menées
sur des garçons et des filles âges et de
4 à 6 ans ont été faites en France mais
aussi en Norvège et au Liban deux pays
aux antipodes en matière de perception
des égalités de genre
le résultat révèle que pour cet enfant
sur dix la figure non jeanrée en
situation de pouvoir est un garçon une
proportion semblable en France au Liban
et même en Norvège
c'est une surprise et là une des
explications possibles c'est que bien
l'expression assez physique du pouvoir
même un petit peu autoritaire du pouvoir
tel que il apparaît dans cette
expérience peut faire penser que c'est
plutôt une forme de pouvoir typiquement
masculin
assez dominante une posture d'expansion
et dans notre côté une posture plus de
construction de subordination peut-être
que ça les enfants l'associent plus
facilement à une forme de pouvoir
changer
ainsi de le plus jeune âge et
indépendamment du contexte culturel
notre cerveau associé au masculin le
pouvoir agressif
d'après ces résultats ce serait donc les
couches primaires ou enfantines de mon
cortex cérébral qui aurait dans ces
images
apprécié davantage la posture dominante
quand elle est incarnée par l'homme que
par la femme
et cela se serait fait à l'insu de mon
plein gré par le simple mouvement des
yeux comme des scientifiques l'ont aussi
observé à partir de ce test
en fait on utilise en psychologie une
méthode qui s'appelle lightracking c'est
le mot français c'est oculométrie c'est
une technique qui va recueillir en fait
les endroits où les individus portent
leur regard
[Musique]
dans cette étude les chercheurs et ils
ont utilisé pour véhiculer l'information
de statut la tenue vestimentaire donc
c'est qui était composé d'hommes donc
avec un costume ou d'homme avec une
tenue un peu plus portuaire et tout le
monde regarde plus en fait les individus
qui véhiculent un statut élevé plutôt
que les individus qui sont en tenus plus
qu'à jouer en fait qui aurait un statut
plus bas donc ça c'est un indice de en
fait spontanément les informations
hiérarchiques associées à un statut
élevé vont attirer l'attention des gens
mais là c'est des hommes sur la grille
il y a des hommes en costume et des
hommes en T-shirt et sur les femmes
alors dans cette étude ce qui était
rapportée en parallèle c'était que
l'attention des individus va se porter
spontanément vers des femmes non pas des
femmes qui vont avoir un statut qui vont
être associé à un statut élevé mais
plutôt des femmes qui vont présenter un
degré d'attractivité élevé
[Musique]
bref quel que soit le costume endossé
par les femmes on ne le regarde pas tant
que leur attractivité
c'est-à-dire concrètement leur pouvoir
d'attraction
[Musique]
mais peut-on en déduire que les
candidates partent à la conquête des
yeux en avec des handicaps pesant dès la
bataille d'affiches d'électorales
confrontons cette hypothèse au vécu de
nos cobayes
[Musique]
pendant la campagne j'ai senti qu'il y
avait une forte présomption
d'incompétence et une présomption d'un
légitimité une présomption d'amaterisme
je sais pas trop ce qui relève de la
jeunesse ou du fait d'être une femme
après dire mais j'ai senti que voilà
c'est c'est présomption là peser un peu
plus fortement sur moi que sur d'autres
candidats qui étaient
masculins avec des codes politiques plus
plus conventionnel on va dire aux
adversaires craignent que si vous
arrivez au pouvoir vous ne serez pas à
la hauteur en termes de sécurité en dit
souvent parfois que les écologistes
seraient un peu laxistes en termes de
sécurité ce que vous avez à dire par
rapport à ça
que la manière dont on aborde une
campagne et la manière dont est les
codes qu'on attend d'un politique sont
encore imprégnés de code assez masculin
par exemple dans des débats le fait de
savoir parler plus forts que les autres
s'imposer en débat prendre toute la
place y compris physiquement ça m'avait
été reproché de ne pas le faire alors
que pour moi c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
attend d'un politique ce qu'on attend ce
qu'on attendait de moi en candidate en
tant que candidate en l'occurrence à
l'époque c'était de savoir exprimer mes
idées clairement essayer d'être
convaincante vis-à-vis des personnes qui
regardaient la télévision en
l'occurrence mais pas forcément de
décrapouiller les autres candidats quoi
ne pas écrabouiller les autres un rejet
de la forme agressive du pouvoir associé
aux garçons comme on l'a démontré le hic
et que la conquête sur le mode offensif
semble tout droit sorti des petits
manuels d'ascension politique
et pourtant
Léonore m'ont conduit a bien été élu
écrabouillant de fait les autres
prétendants
comment s'y est-elle prise
sa recette n'a rien à voir avec la prise
de pouvoir au sens classique du terme
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
[Musique]
ces images ont l'air de rien et pourtant
je sais que Pierre est derrière son
écran dans cette salle l'ambiance de
banal MJC se joue un processus politique
inédit
j'ai été élu au sein d'une démarche qui
s'appelle Poitiers collectif qui une
démarche qui s'est construite en deux
ans à l'échelle de la ville de Poitiers
et qui visait vraiment à redonner
confiance en la politique en faisant les
choses dans le bon sens ce qu'on
considérait être le bon sens la double
titre d'ailleurs donc en mettant d'abord
le projet avant les têtes et puis les
têtes donc l'équipe avant la tête donc
on a passé un an à construire un
programme de manière très ouverte sur la
ville très participative ensuite on a
désigné une première équipe de candidats
à 20 premiers candidats et ensuite sur
ces 20 personnes on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une élection sans candidats
c'est à dire qu'il y avait pas de
candidature a priori mais chacun était
invité à désigner quelle personne quel
homme quelle femme lui semblait le plus
à même d'incarner la démarche citoyenne
qu'on voulait porter aux responsabilités
à Poitiers
je pense pouvoir faire se voir
l'engagement et l'implication
dans Leonor a fait preuve depuis octobre
2018 et avant et donc c'était une soirée
publique qui a duré 5h30 en live sur
Facebook et cette manière de désigner
les candidats c'était vraiment l'un des
premiers principes qu'on a posé
lorsqu'on a créé notre démarche parce
que les désignations de type primaire où
il faut faire acte de candidature on se
rend compte que ça exclut souvent les
personnes qui sentent pas sur d'elle et
en particulier les femmes et donc le
candidat aujourd'hui l'élu il tire sa
légitimité du groupe d'un collectif il
tire pas sa légitimité du fait d'être
plus extraordinaire que les autres ou
plus volontaire ou désirant plus
puisqu'on est toujours que c'est le
désir qui est voilà je pense vraiment
que le désir ne fait pas partie des
enfin il faut
il faut être prêt et consacré beaucoup
d'énergie il faut être prêt à tenir bon
sur sur ces valeurs et il faut être prêt
à être comment dire à être redevable
collectif sans cesse de ce qu'on fait de
rendre compte de son action mais le fait
de vouloir le pouvoir n'est pas
forcément pour moi la première qualité
qu'on attend d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique
[Applaudissements]
des femmes moins volontaires moins
portées par le désir d'être là candidate
le constat n'est pas neuf mais il sonne
curieusement quand celles qui les
prononce vient d'une génération
normalement à franchie de ces notions
poussiéreuses alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
une jeune femme de 29 ans serait-elle
moins désireuse qu'un garçon de prendre
le pouvoir
une énigme soumise à notre panel de
chercheurs
dans leur laboratoire Julie lemaireur et
Jérôme Baker étudie le comportement
social des souris pour la recherche
médicale
des souris pas des hommes mais il y a
des points communs
on a beaucoup de gènes en commun même si
c'est parfois difficile à admettre avec
les souris et du coup on a aussi
beaucoup de mécanismes de fonctionnement
de notre cerveau qui sont très communs
[Musique]
en compilant leurs données pour ce
documentaire ils ont mis en lumière une
drôle de différence entre mâle et
femelle
pour collaboratoires on utilise
classiquement deux tests de sociabilité
l'un qui s'appelle le test des trois
chambres qui permet de mesurer si une
souris préfère interagir avec un
congénère ou avec une souris en peluche
un objet
on a d'abord calculé le nombre de
contacts tout court que font la souris
avec le container ou avec le jouet et
dans ce paramètre là on peut voir qui il
n'y a pas de différence entre les deux
sexes par contre quand on regarde
maintenant le temps passé en contact
social avec une souris ou avec le jouet
on voit clairement que les femelles
passent moins de temps à interagir avec
le congénère que les mâles
plus il y a des toiles plus le résultat
est robuste on fait le rapport de ces
contacts avec la souris et avec le jouet
et on calcule cette pourcentage de
préférence sociale et on voit que si les
mâles comme les femelles préfèrent quand
même passer du temps avec une souris
vivante qu'avec un jouet en plus les
femelles préfèrent un peu moins et c'est
assez significatif c'est-à-dire que on a
vraiment une mise en retrait de la des
femelles par rapport au mal
et le deuxième test qu'on utilise c'est
un test d'interaction sociale directe où
on met dans une arène de souris de même
sexe de même âge et on regarde comment
ils interagissent entre eux ils sont des
animaux qui ne se connaissent pas donc
on a la situation de découverte de
l'inconnu
aussi bien le nombre de contacts que le
temps passé a explorer cet animal
inconnu est un peu plus faible chez les
femelles par rapport au mâles et aussi
si on regarde leur comportement après un
contact on voit qu'elles ont tendance à
se toiler davantage après ce contact
comme si elles aimaient pas trop en fait
ce contact du coup quelles conséquence
vous tirez de ces compilations de
données qu'est-ce que ça dit des
comportements des maladies femelles
probablement je pense que ça reflète le
côté adaptatif du comportement social
pour les mâles ou pour les femelles et
c'est pas le même de manière assez
instinctive donc pour les mâles on sait
qu'il y a un côté dominance et défense
du territoire alors que chez les
femelles on va avoir une réserve un peu
plus importante qui est probablement dû
à l'évolution tout simplement parce que
la femelle il va falloir qu'elle défend
sa progéniture elle va se préserver un
peu plus du contact avec les autres et
se mettre un peu plus en retrait donc
elle le fait de manière biologique en
fait sans avoir besoin de mettre un
facteur culturel en plus les hommes ont
plus généralement plus de testostérone
que les femmes ça veut pas dire que les
femmes ne l'ont pas mais le toi est
moins mais au-delà d'être
associé à la à la sexualisation des
individus en fait la testostérone elle a
un rôle très important dans les
comportements par exemple de prise de
risque et aussi de dans les situations
de compétition en fait pendant l'exemple
d'un match de tennis si on mesure le
taux de testostérone entre les deux
participants du match et ben chez le
vainqueur on aura on observera un taux
de testostérone plus élevé que chez le
perdant à l'inverse si vous mesurez
avant le match le taux de testostérone
de des deux joueurs celui qui a le plus
de testostérone avant à plus de chances
de gagner le match et ça marche de la
même manière si on utilise des indices
liés à la hiérarchie par exemple des
voitures on plaçait les individus
masculins dans une voiture donc qui
était soit une voiture très haut de
gamme genre une Porsche ou soit une
voiture un peu plus bas de gamme genre
par exemple un Scénic et en fait le fait
d'être en d'un apparade au statut la
Porsche semblait avoir un impact sur le
niveau de testostérone des individus et
pas lorsqu'il était dans le Scénic et
même quand la voiture est à l'arrêt les
exemples que vous allez citer sur le
pouvoir c'est beaucoup des exemples qui
concernent les hommes oui
dans une Kangoo est-ce que sur la femme
ça va être pareil ou pas est-ce qu'il y
a des études ça c'est la question c'est
ça qui serait intéressant de savoir
est-ce que par exemple d'autres
effectivement on parle beaucoup de
testostérone et
prise de risque et compétition mais en
fait peut-être que testostérone et prise
de risque et compétition chez la femme
c'est pas du tout la bonne approche en
fait parce que c'est ce modèle là c'est
le modèle de comment la masculinité
s'associe à la hiérarchie mais peut-être
que comment la féminité s'associe à la
hiérarchie et au pouvoir c'est pas en
passant par en tout cas d'un point de
vue biologique au modèle testostérone
vous le savez madame la ministre les
accords en attendant que la science se
penche sur ce sujet
la loi a pris les devants dès le 6 juin
2000 elle acte que les femmes ont la
plupart du temps besoin d'être incités
pour osé y aller le texte sur la parité
pose un principe autant de candidats que
de candidates pour les scrutins de liste
c'est à dire les prochaines élections
européennes régionales et municipales la
loi sur la parité a fait qu'on est venu
me demander parce qu'on avait besoin de
femmes donc on est venu me demander de
participer à une liste pour les
élections municipales
c'était en 2008 je crois
j'étais déjà pas si jeune que ça et
franchement moi la politique ça
m'intéressait pas plus que ça je crois
d'ailleurs que je n'allais même pas
forcément voter à toutes les élections
et je voyais ça comme un monde masculin
un peu ma goût d'ailleurs c'est un peu
le l'image parfois qu'on a ça magouille
là-dedans donc ça m'intéressait pas
vraiment et je me suis dit tiens ça sera
intéressant de faire une expérience de
voir pourquoi pas
vous avez accepté parce que là vous
étiez dans le cadre d'un collectif
soutenu par le collectif mais ça c'était
le temps de la campagne et après
vous étiez effectivement collectivement
porté mais après c'est vous qui êtes
mère vous n'êtes plus dans le collectif
existe toujours on a encore très très
actif et ça fait partie de nos
engagements et en tout cas ça fait
partie de ce que je souhaite vraiment
porter fort c'est le fait d'avoir
toujours un pied dans la mairie et un
pied hors de la mairie je voulais quand
même amener vraiment une proximité
physique une accessibilité du politique
voilà qu'on ne soit pas dans une tour
d'ivoire même si le bureau est ivoire
mais en tout cas voilà que que nous
puissions être physiquement proches en
tout cas accessible des citoyens par
tous les moyens que ce soit les
permanences que ce soit les réseaux
sociaux et c'est à la fois ce qu'on me
ce qu'on me reproche parce que j'en fais
souvent trop on me dit ma mère vous
devriez pas répondre en direct aux
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux ou
répondre et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
citoyen il attend de ses élus cette
proximité cette facilité d'accès
j'enchaîne avec la deuxième question
qu'en est-il donc Antoine jadan pardon
qui me demande ce qu'il en est du projet
de d'augmentation de la taxe foncière
alors là encore je sais que c'est un
sujet qui a beaucoup fait parler de lui
dans la presse depuis le conseil
communautaire de grands Poitiers
rendre des comptes la vision verticale
du chef qui connaît tout n'est pas la
tasse de thé de ne cobayes politiques ce
que confirme cette petite
expérimentation
à la fin de l'interview dans le bureau
panoramique des maires de Biarritz nous
avons demandé à myder arrostéguy de nous
montrer comment elle habite cet espace
qu'elle a mis à ses couleurs
étonnamment la première pause du pouvoir
qu'elle a prise a été d'enlever ses
escarpins pour se mettre dans le canapé
avec sa pile de dossier
et quand est arrivé le rendez-vous de
travail elle est allée s'installer
autour de la table ronde moins formelle
que le bureau où elle ne s'attarde que
pour signer des paraphes en échangeant
avec le directeur de cabinet
les pauses qui se font les moments qui
sont symboliques pour moi de ma manière
d'être mère il y a effectivement le fait
d'avoir ma porte toujours ouverte c'est
très important pour moi et ça je l'ai
mis en place dès ma première journée ici
la porte est toujours ouverte c'est les
élus peuvent venir
quand ils veulent et lorsque je reçois
des gens la plupart du temps c'est pas
pour pour donner audience c'est vraiment
pour travailler donc je suis à la table
qui est plus confortable pour travailler
pour avoir mille papier autour de soi
des dossiers et donc la grande table qui
est derrière vous une table en bois que
j'ai choisi exprès après pour être
honnête avec vous à chaque fois que je
peux je sors de mon bureau pour aller
prendre un café avec les copains donc
enfin bon est-ce que enfin pour moi
l'une des postures notamment dans le
côté maintenir la cohésion du groupe
enfin ça ne serait pas complet si vous
ne montrez pas en train de prendre un
café avec les autres élus quoi du coup
mais je sais pas si c'est possible pour
vous point commun de ces images la mère
elle a l'air de Biarritz c'est l'écolo
de Poitiers refuse que leur pouvoir
puisse être interprétés comme une
domination
on se souvient que le chercheur
Jean-Baptiste valdenerst a montré que
les enfants associés aux garçons le
pouvoir agressif
mais que se passe-t-il quand ce pouvoir
prend d'autres formes
une deuxième expérience
où cette fois le pouvoir ne s'exprimait
pas par des postures physiques par des
postures corporelles alors on a utilisé
des marionnettes qui étaient cette fois
très Enrique
une marionnette garçon on va jouer à
cache-cache oh oui on adore jouer à
cache-cache il y a un petit dialogue
comme ça qui se fait et à un moment
donné elles vont commencer à disparaître
et les enfants vont devoir deviner qui
va dire quoi allez c'est moi qui compte
ah non c'est moi qui compte moi j'ai
envie de compter et mais moi aussi j'ai
envie de compter et puis d'ailleurs
c'est moi qui décide de tout et
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui vais décider à
quoi on va jouer après d'accord d'accord
donc moi je décide de rien et toi tu
choisis tout donc les marionnettes vont
continuer à parler derrière le théâtre
et après on va montrer les deux
marionnettes et on va demander à vos
enfants alors qui est-ce qui a dit ceci
qu'est-ce qui est dit cela
donc il y avait ensuite une deuxième
histoire qui portait cette fois sur un
point assez important dans le pouvoir
qui est le contrôle des ressources le la
quantité de ressources qu'on maîtrise
les deux marionnettes sont toujours face
aux enfants et puis à un moment donné il
y a le marchand de glace qui passe
et puis cette fois on les entend dire
moi j'ai plein de sous dans ma poche et
j'ai 10 pièces dans ma poche moi j'ai
pas beaucoup de sous j'ai que trois
pièces dans ma poche moi j'ai beaucoup
d'argent moi j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
quels ont été les résultats qu'on a fait
cette expérience en France et au Liban
pas en Norvège cette fois et on a des
résultats très similaires en France et
au Liban mais cette fois on a une
différence entre les filles et les
garçons à savoir que les garçons dans
les deux histoires pensent que le
personnage qui a le plus de pouvoir
c'est-à-dire celui qui décide ou celui
qui a plus de ressources c'est le garçon
par contre les filles elles sont autour
de 50/50 et ça ça veut dire que
peut-être il y a deux facteurs
antagonistes qui jouent à la fois un
facteur qui conduit à penser que son
propre genre est plutôt dominant et à la
fois un facteur qui relève simplement de
l'observation de ce qui se passe dans
l'environnement à savoir que ce sont
plutôt les hommes qui vont avoir
tendance à dominer donc c'est deux
facteurs s'alignent chez les garçons
alors que chez les filles les deux
facteurs sont antagonistes
[Musique]
alors nous sommes accompagnés
desservices Madame La diatrie Générale
des Services monsieur DG à travaux donc
une question qui va être traitée par
Géraldine qui va faire la présentation
d'un événement ouais vas-y Xavier
on peut pas y rajouter Red Bull Biarritz
Océan au resto
il
ok c'est mieux le marquant ok
bonne intervention Xavier
majorité elle est à l'image des citoyens
c'est à dire que elle a elle a envie de
parler elle a envie de décider et j'en
pose pas des choses à majorité s'il y a
pas d'autres questions on avance sur le
le gros le gros burger de la soirée le
budget Édouard
des éléments qui ne sont proposés
260 mails 14000 coups de téléphone et
150 SMS
on s'est construit pendant la campagne
sur un rassemblement de d'origine
politique différente beaucoup de ce
qu'on appelle la société civile et donc
ils sont venus autour de ma personne
pour le projet qu'on a construit
ensemble et aussi par la façon que j'ai
eu de travailler avec eux c'est à dire
alors toujours leur laisser la parole
leur laisser la capacité de s'exprimer
et la capacité de revenir sur une
décision sur lequel ils sont pas
d'accord donc oui c'est un en permanence
un arbitrage de l'équilibre entre les
citoyens les élus l'administration
oui donc ça c'est nouveau comme manière
de fonctionner par rapport à la
tradition politique je le pense
c'est entouré de cette équipe qui comme
elle aime le dire enfin de la droite au
communiste que Maïder a roseguy a
conquis la mairie et qu'elle dirige la
ville
mais sa façon de raconter d'incarner le
pouvoir
d'étonnes quand on se souvient que son
parti LR Adam son ADN le gaullisme et
les codes verticaux du pouvoir
évidemment moins simple pour une femme
que pour un homme d'endosser le costume
de De Gaulle ou de Jupiter mais de là
devenir chantre de la co-construction il
y a comme un pied de nez à l'histoire
politique
alors est-ce une mode un petit salé ou
une vraie alternative à la figure
imposante du fameux Malfa
les images que vous voyez là c'est la
société des babouins chaque mois que
j'étudie c'est l'archétype de ça on voit
deux mâles qui se battent qui parfois se
battent à mort
babouin chacma chimpanzé ces espèces
très étudiées par les primatologues
incarnent la vision patriarcale du monde
une vision que bas-en-bresse des études
plus récentes dont celle des lits du
char
[Musique]
qu'il arrive à faire c'est il est
dominant socialement c'est à dire et
monopolise les ressources il contrôle
vraiment l'accès à la nourriture l'accès
aux femelles mais par contre il a pas
toujours un pouvoir de décision qui est
plus important que les autres et sur
certains types de décisions il
semblerait que ce soit relativement
démocratique et que Ben les femelles
participent aussi à décider par exemple
où est-ce qu'on va fourrager ou chercher
de la nourriture ou est-ce qu'on va
dormir ce soir et ça c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas le monopole du mal alpha pour
autant qu'on le sache parce que c'est
des recherches qui sont en cours et on
sait pas tout sur ces questions là donc
en fait ça me permet de poser une
distinction entre deux types de pouvoir
qui sont faites en la recherche sur le
comportement animal et qui sont je pense
pour lequel on peut tout à fait faire le
parallèle avec ce qui se passe dans les
sociétés humaines il y a ce qu'on
appelle la dominance sociale et le
pouvoir de monopoliser les ressources
d'une part et puis d'autre part le
pouvoir décisionnel ce qu'on appelle
aussi du leadership qui est la capacité
à peser dans les décisions collectives
donc en fait ce fameux modèle du mal
alpha qu'on a souvent conceptualisé dans
le dans l'accès au pouvoir dans les
sociétés humaines en fait il existe pas
vraiment chez les animaux bah disons en
tout cas effectivement
il faut même dans les sociétés qui sont
très dominées par les enfin nous on se
rend compte que c'est vraiment pas
toutes les sociétés qui sont très
dominées par les mâles socialement et
que même dans ces sociétés là les miens
ils ont pas tous les pouvoirs en général
exactement c'est vraiment important de
rappeler que nos deux les deux espèces
qui sont les plus proches de nous c'est
vraiment le chimpanzé et le bonobo et il
y a vraiment d'un côté effectivement les
les mal dominants leader etc dans les
sociétés chimpanzées mais il y a
vraiment le contre-pied dans les
sociétés Bonobo et a priori il y a pas
de raison de penser que on est plus
proche de lui que de l'eau
après chez les espèces où c'est les
femelles qui sont socialement dominantes
sur les mâles donc on comprend pas tout
des trajectoires vers le pouvoir
particulièrement des femelles il y a
probablement au moins deux mécanismes
qui sont importants le premier mécanisme
c'est des physiologies ou des
anatomiques qui interdit aux mal de de
forcer le sexe chez les hyènes le
magazine il est très bien compris
la conséquence de ça c'est que c'est
très difficile pour un mal de sa couler
avec une femelle sans son accord
et donc les femelles vont décider ou non
s'accoupler avec un mâle et donc si le
mal il est
dominant violent etc elles peuvent
refuser de s'accoupler avec lui et ça te
plaît uniquement avec les mâles qui vont
se montrer plus coopératif
un autre mécanisme qui les alliances
sociales en fait chez beaucoup de
mammifères les femelles elles vont pas
quitter leur groupe natale elles vont
vivre toute leur vie dans leur groupe
natale alors que les mâles fréquemment
vont aller à la puberté dispersée dans
un autre groupe et donc dans ce contexte
ça veut dire qu'une femelle quand elle
est dans son groupe elle a plein de
sœurs de des mères des tentes enfin elle
a tout un réseau d'apparentés qui sont
souvent très prêtes à les soutenir dans
les conflits de façon à
dominer soit une autre femelle soit
parfois un mal
[Musique]
bref le modèle chimpanzé du fameux mâle
alpha à une alternative
le modèle Bonobo de collaboration
tentons le portrait robot de ce leader
collectif versus celui très classique de
son cousin chimpanzé avant le système
était beaucoup plus pyramidal c'est à
dire que l'ensemble des décisions
étaient prises par le maire et que la
décision du maire s'imposait à la vie
des autres élus on se heurte quand même
à une culture une culture de
l'administration une culture de du
service qui a été très prégnante
Ian me prédécesseurs est resté plus de
20 ans au pouvoir et il était je dirais
traditionnellement dans l'exercice du
pouvoir de ce qu'on appelle le mal blanc
de plus de 50 ans donc quelque chose de
très paternaliste qui donne beaucoup
d'ordre moi vraiment je pars de
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que ma décision
intervient lorsqu'un élu la demande
lorsqu'un élu a besoin de mon avis et
bien je je le donne et puis je tranche
lorsqu'il y a des avis divergents au
sein de la majorité et ça existe mais je
considère pas a priori que toutes les
décisions doivent passer par moi alors
après j’arbitre et je dis et je décide
et ils ont compris ils disent souvent
mais à la fin c'est Madame le Maire qui
décide mais je te préviens moi si tu
fais pas cette école en premier moi je
suis pas d'accord c'est toi qui décidera
mais moi je suis pas d'accord et je sais
que quand j'entends ça je me dis non là
tu vas pas parce que si tu as ton
adjoint qui est pas d'accord qu'on
prenne cette décision là c'est que c'est
pas une bonne décision le pouvoir pour
moi c'est c'est avant tout le la
responsabilité qu'on nous donne quand au
fait de prendre des décisions et ces
décisions se prennent avant tout sur la
base d'un de valeur d'objectifs
politiques forts et pas forcément sur la
base de compétences de connaissances ce
qui compte avant tout ce qui compte
avant tout pour moi dans l'exercice du
pouvoir c'est le fait d'avoir une
boussole solidement ancrée et
quel guide les décisions qu'on doit
prendre quand on a le pouvoir
et surtout ça permet d'être très
transparent dans l'attribution des fonds
publics réponse seulement selon cette
théorie Bonobo du pouvoir le maire ne
sort pas du lot par la somme de ses
compétences mais par sa propension à
tenir le cap du groupe
sympathique mais n'est-ce pas un peu
trop humble face aux nombreux enjeux de
la fonction de maire et ne retourne pas
dans une forme d'inhibition intériorisée
comme étant typiquement féminine pour
répondre commençons par faire une
expérience
observez cette figure on la présente
quelques instants à de jeunes collégiens
puisant la retire et ils doivent la
reproduire de mémoire
cette expérience a lieu avec plusieurs
groupes d'élèves à une différence près
un certain le chercheur présente cette
figure comme de la géométrie à d'autres
du dessin dans le premier cas quand les
élèves pensent être évalués en géométrie
les garçons font nettement mieux en
revanche chez ceux qui pensent être en
train de dessiner les performances
s'inversent et les filles passent devant
c'est parfaitement inexplicable d'un
point de vue biologique cette affaire
[Musique]
la problématique femme et pouvoir si les
femmes ont moins de pouvoir dans un tas
de sphères c'est parce qu'on leur fait
très tôt un procès en incompétence dans
des domaines qui
traduisent les capacités à se montrer
rationnel à se montrer logique oui pour
vous voilà on est dans le même univers
le pouvoir c'est rationnel donc on est
dans les mêmes qualités que tous les
maths beaucoup plus tard du plafond de
verre etc mais en réalité avant le
plafond de verre il y a un procès en
incompétence en incompétence en matière
rationalité de raisonnement logique qui
organise ensuite ces croyances qui sont
très dures qui sont très difficiles à
déconstruire d'une infériorité des
filles relativement garçons dans le
domaine des mathématiques et des
sciences et ensuite à l'âge adulte de la
prise de responsabilité difficile si en
effet le stéréotype à quelque chose de
fondé de confier les rênes du
grand-maman entreprise qui réclament
quand même des décisions rationnelles
etc à des femmes
et le stéréotype agit à un tel point que
les femmes s'en imprègnent de manière
inconsciente
on retrouve nos élèves quelques années
plus tard en école d'ingénieur avec un
autre test cette fois de raisonnement
logique très difficile
il faut remplir la case manquante avec
l'un des 8 éléments proposés quand vous
avez donné la bonne réponse vous passez
à la matrice suivante il y en a 40
dans cette configuration dites standard
les résultats des garçons sont bien
meilleurs que ceux des filles
[Musique]
mais avec d'autres étudiants
l'expérimentateur ajoute une petite
précision avant le début du test il n'y
a pas de différence entre les hommes et
les femmes sur ce genre de test
cette petite phrase toute bête produit
un vrai miracle
les filles font beaucoup mieux et mieux
que les garçons
d'abord les garçons eux semblent plutôt
démotivés c'est à partir du moment où
finalement on fait sauter l'enjeu de
cette comparaison entre les garçons et
les filles et les filles réussissent
mieux parce que l'interprétation de
l'erreur n'est pas la même il est normal
de faire des erreurs quand on fait un
test difficile mais si l'on n'a pas à
ajouter en plus cette crainte de
confirmer la mauvaise réputation en fait
au groupe d'appartenance ça va mieux
parce que cette crainte
place les filles dans cette situation
qu'on appelle l'attention divisée
c'est-à-dire on accorde de l'attention
au test mais en même temps
s'enclenche une autre boucle qui réclame
de l'attention qui est cette menace
reproduire un échec qui viendrait dire
encore que les filles sont moins
compétentes que les garçons et donc
évidemment si vous avez moins
d'attention pour faire un test qui en
réclame beaucoup aux vêtements bien la
sortie si on vous libère de cette
pression évaluative imposée par le
stéréotype presque mécaniquement les
filles font mieux
l'attention divisée en cas d'erreur
voilà qui nous renvoie au gourde de la
vie publique
ces fameuses gaffes que font hommes et
femmes politiques mais qui collent
davantage à la peau des secondes une
constante aussi vieille que les journaux
télévisés
Edith Cresson et les expulsions par
charters de clandestins
qui partent en voyage avec des en
vacances avec des prix inférieurs là ça
sera totalement gratuit Dominique Voynet
la marée noire de l'Erika ce n'est pas
comme certains me pressaient de le dire
hier la catastrophe du siècle si bête
Ndiaye et les masques avant la crise du
covid est-ce que vous avez acheté des
masques pour vous et vos enfants ah non
pas du tout
vous rigolez mais là la question c'est
de savoir est-ce qu'on va acheter
celle qui les prononce comme le fameux
sparadrap du capitaine Haddock Dominique
voannet sème une phrase maladroite sans
se douter qu'elle va récolter une
tempête politique sarudait c'est
maladresse et ses vérités pas toujours
bonnes à dire heurte les classiques du
PS un homme qui fait qui fait qui dit
une bêtise c'est une bourde une femme
qui dit une bêtise c'est une gourde
fatalité ou flair de notre équipe de
tournage Léonore mon conduit entre du
cyclone quelques semaines après le début
de ce film
en cause une petite phrase et une grosse
polémique autour de l'aérien qui ne
devrait plus faire partie des rêves
d'enfants on se remet dans l'ambiance
plus lourde qu'à aérienne
l'Amérique Poitiers vient d'envoyer ce
mail au président de l'aéroclub je le
tiens à vous alerter que la ville de
Poitiers ne compte pas soutenir le sport
motorisé l'association recevait 8000
euros par an jusque là ce sera donc 0
d'ici deux ans de l'argent public qui
contribuait à financer aussi des
baptêmes du ciel pour enfants situations
de handicap pour justifier sa décision
voici l'argument choisi cette semaine en
conseil municipal par la mer écologiste
je pense que vous vous rendez pas compte
aujourd'hui de des rêves en fait
auxquelles on doit des rêves dont on
doit préserver les enfants en fait enfin
les rien c'est triste mais ne doit plus
faire partie des rêves d'enfants
aujourd'hui depuis la polémique enfle le
ministre des Transports ancien pilote de
ligne s'indigne sur Twitter faites de ta
vie un rêve et d'un rêve une réalité
Saint-Exupéry pilote écrivain et
humaniste loin de ses élus vibrations et
moribond
quand nous retournons voir la jeune mère
de Poitiers nous évoquons bien sur
l'impact de cette maladresse qui a dû la
mortifier
[Musique]
c'était assez violent clairement pour
c'était assez violent pour moi et aussi
pour l'ensemble de l'équipe municipale
qui s'est retrouvé
on m'a parlé de Poitiers pour un motif
qu'on aurait préféré bien différent
j'imagine qu'il a fallu un certain
courage non pour aller à la radio dire
où c'est eux qui vous ont sollicité
c'est vous qui vous êtes dit allez j'y
vais je oui non non c'est moi qui oui
oui non c'est est-ce que vous regrettez
cette phrase je suis tout à fait
consciente de la maladresse de cette
phrase et de l'incompréhension qu'elle a
pu générer chez les personnes et en
effet aujourd'hui je cette cause mérite
d'être défendue avec des termes
peut-être plus plus à droite et est-ce
que vous comprenez dans le fond j'avais
rien à cacher en fait il y avait la
maladresse des propos à reconnaître mais
aussi le fait d'assumer une décision
d'assumer de dire que ce large
médiatique n'est pas normal et c'est
aussi ma responsabilité de le dire ça me
tenait à cœur de pouvoir dire tout ça
dans un dans un tempo assez assez rapide
après la polémique et après coup de sur
le moyen terme j'ai vraiment eu envie
que cette cette polémique elle nous soit
utile j'ai un peu fait du judo avec
cette polémique là on le prenant non pas
comme une faiblesse mais comme une force
puisqu'il y a de l'intérêt pour Poitiers
sur les questions d'aéronautique et bien
j'ai invité la Fédération Française
d'aéronautique à venir nous voir à venir
envisager avec nous qu'elle
développements on pourrait avoir pour
notre petit aéroport local par exemple
est-ce qu'on pourrait en faire une
plateforme ou
s'imagine un petit peu une partie de
l'aérien de demain j'ai rencontré les
visiblement Leonor m'ont conduit ne
souffre pas du syndrome de l'attention
divisée que pointait Pascal Huguet et
bien suite la fameuse polémique et
j'avais reçu de nombreux courriers donc
j'avais répondu à chacun des courriers
mais certains comprenaient des des
petits travaux manuels à faire soi-même
donc un petit avion à monter soi-même et
puis alors bon le cabinet c'est bien
amusé aussi et puis j'ai eu le droit
infopilote et puis les petits goodies de
la Fédération Française aéronautique
donc j'ai commencé une collection
d'avions ça fait partie de mon identité
aujourd'hui cette question d'avion donc
au terme de cette enquête risquons une
hypothèse pour expliquer cela dans le
pouvoir Bonobo le chef doit négocier et
conclure des alliances ce qui l'oblige à
débattre avec des contradicteurs
on est loin du bonheur et du chef en
surplomb des images d'Épinal si loin que
tous les deux mois Léonore m'ont conduit
retourne rendre des comptes devant
Poitiers collectif qu'il avait désigné
elle a cherché dans l'image sans signe
distinctifs parmi les citoyens on s'est
interrogé sur le symbole de ce pouvoir
récusant le vertical
comment le définir hormis par ce qu'il
n'est pas
en regardant avec nous ce film qui
s'achève Mariette d'arrigran sémiologue
a retenu deux images étonnantes Maïder a
restegui prenant la pose du pouvoir sur
son canapé crème et Léonor mont conduit
dans le cercle de son collectif de banal
MJC
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ce cercle est inclusif c'est c'est un
des récits de notre société aujourd'hui
vouloir être inclusif prendre tout le
monde et puis une démocratie cherchant à
se redéfinir comme ça après à un moment
donné il faut qu'une personne prenne la
décision donc c'est un en fait le cercle
et tout de suite hybride tout de suite
il y a de la verticalité qui se met
dedans dans l'exercice réel de la chose
et ça me fait observer et attendre
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore tout
à fait là mais une figure nouvelle de
femme politique qui répondrait à cibler
l'archétype de la bienfaitrice
c'est à dire une femme qui est capable
de réconcilier les forces
diffraction de la société toutes les
sociétés
occidentales c'est l'archipel français
si vous voulez mais aussi plus largement
le désir d'être en guerre des âges des
sexes des classes tout est guerrier tout
est agonistique dans notre société et
puis j'ai beaucoup aimé cette pause
disons mis allongée sans le savoir je
pense elle se remet dans les pas des
représentations ancestrales c'est-à-dire
avant
là on est dans l'Antiquité cinq siècles
avant Jésus-Christ et c'est une période
qui du monde romain qui a été
parfaitement occultée ou Vénus est une
figure politique
je me suis aperçue ça en travaillant sur
la notion de virilité qui n'est pas en
Ré au départ c'est la qualité des femmes
comme des hommes qui vont bien et on a
les anciens appelé ça avoir du Vénus
comme on a du tonus si vous voulez et
donc il l'a représenté cette DS là à ce
moment-là comme ça sur une sorte de il y
avait pas de canapé bien sûr mais de
couches sur sa coquille couche qui était
aussi une sorte de bateau et là elle
allait gouverner la cité et donc il y a
je crois de cela aujourd'hui qui nous
revient ça n'est pas parce que on n'est
pas dressé comme si vous voulez un guide
spirituel une Jeanne d'Arc avec une
lance ou une Amazon comment tous les
attributs du pouvoir de type masculin
quand on n'est pas prête au combat et
les deux exemples qu'on n'est pas dans
un référentiel de pouvoir exactement il
y a un référentiel de pouvoir ancestral
qui n'est pas verticale
avoir une dose d'audace pardon de Vénus
pour descendre de l'Olympe et s'allonger
tranquille en femme forte et moderne les
reines de la pop culture l'ont
parfaitement compris on peut être
horizontal mais également viril au sens
puissant du terme
dans ma ville de Strasbourg Jeanne
d'Arsen et lui elle aussi en 2020 a bien
compris le symbole elle a fait prendre
l'ascenseur à son bureau de mer du haut
du septième panoramique il est descendu
au premier étage
[Musique]